[Aplausos]
[Música]
con un poco más de 283 mil kilómetros
cuadrados Ecuador es uno de los países
más pequeños de Sudamérica pero pese a
ello en los últimos años las tormentas
de su clima político se han convertido
en Auténticos ciclones Ecuador se ha
convertido en un país que no para de
generar más más taquillados políticos
con su particular dosis de Conspiración
revueltas públicas e incluso exilios y
persecuciones internacionales el fin de
ciclo de Rafael Correa la tradición de
su vicepresidente Lenin Moreno y las
constantes sublevaciones de los grupos
indígenas hicieron que en 2021 llegara
al poder Guillermo lasso un presidente
que se ha jugado su capital y su
proyecto político en un referéndum que
ahora le ha dejado completamente
noqueado el pueblo ecuatoriano nos ha
pedido nos ha pedido a todos los
partidos y agrupaciones que dejemos de
abonar
rencillas entre nosotros y pongamos de
una vez por todas a solucionar los
problemas urgentes y concretos de
nuestra gente con el parlamento
encontrarás intentó saltarse al
legislativo y sacar adelante su programa
de gobierno buscando directamente el
apoyo popular lo hizo en un referéndum
para modificar la Constitución Ya sabéis
que en América Latina pues las
constituciones nunca son versiones
definitivas son prácticamente Por así
decirlo borradores de quita y por
de esta forma el pasado 5 de febrero del
2023 los Ecuatorianos fueron convocados
a las urnas para escoger a los cargos
políticos municipales pero también para
pronunciarse sobre las ocho reformas
constitucionales promovidas por lasso y
también claro está por extensión para
mostrar su apoyo o su rechazo a este
gobierno era una jugada de todo una
carta por parte de un gobierno
desesperado arrinconado y bloqueado sin
embargo queridos amigos amigas las cosas
no pudieron salirles peor el presidente
no sólo perdió el referéndum sino
también poco capital político que le
quedaba ahora bien la pregunta es cómo
se ha llegado hasta aquí Cómo ha podido
el presidente de Ecuador lanzarse a
semejante órgano estamos a las puertas
del regreso de Rafael Correa y quizás la
pregunta más importante de todas Qué día
antes está pasando con Ecuador Pues bien
en este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes tenemos
que comprender cómo se ha llegado hasta
aquí arranquemos
[Música]
lazo las eles del cambio
hagamos un pequeño rewind aquí
visualpolitika hace aproximadamente un
año os contamos en este vídeo como Lenin
Moreno le había dado la espalda al
socialismo del siglo XXI y como se había
desvinculado por completo de su
predecesor Rafael Correa lo que viene a
ser lo mismo bajo el gobierno de Moreno
entre otras cosas se impulsó otro
referéndum constitucional donde se
prohibió la reelección presidencial y se
inhabilitó a las personas condenadas por
corrupción para ejercer cualquier cargo
público además también se llevó a cabo
un importante ajuste macroeconómico
sobre el gasto del Estado para así
reducir el déficit fiscal Claro que es
muy posible que muchos recordáis Cómo
terminó toda esta historia
[Música]
en cualquier caso sea como sea Moreno
consigue sobrevivir a toda aquella
hecatón de política logró negociar con
la confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del Ecuador una tregua
mientras el plan de ajuste de las
cuentas públicas seguía en marcha pero
de forma mucho más gradual y así es como
consigo llegar hasta el final de su
mandato de esta forma en abril del 2021
los Ecuatorianos fueron convocados para
escoger entre Andrés araud que fue Ni
más ni menos ojo con el nombrecito que
ministro coordinador de conocimiento y
talento humano de Rafael Correa y
Guillermo lasso un renombrado empresario
banquero que ya había sido candidato a
la presidencia en 2013 y 2017 Pues bien
estas elecciones de 2021 parecían claves
en ella se dirimía si de una vez por
todas Ecuador votaba por pasar página o
en cambio volvía a caer en manos del
correísmo y queridos amigos amigas esta
vez Ecuador dijo se acabó 11 de abril de
2021 sinceramente creíamos que ganábamos
pero nuestras proyecciones eran erradas
Rafael Correa Así es como dio comienzo
una nueva era una nueva etapa que priori
suponía un cambio de rumbo completo
Ecuador le dio un portazo a la izquierda
fue la ratificación del giro ya
emprendido por Lenin Moreno lasso
recibió el encargo de construir un nuevo
Ecuador pero la pregunta es realmente lo
está consiguiendo pues atentos
lazo la tercera fue la vencida
[Música]
Guillermo Alberto Santiago lasso Mendoza
no es precisamente una cara nueva todo
lo contrario es un viejo conocido del
establisment ecuatoriano lasso proviene
de una familia de ingresos medios fue el
último de 11 hermanos y con tan solo 15
años Tuvo que comenzar a trabajar al
mismo tiempo que hacía la secundaria no
lo hizo eso sí en un oficio cualquiera
sino que comenzó a trabajar como Cadete
y auxiliar de cuentas en alguna de las
entidades financieras de la bolsa de
valores de su ciudad natal Guayaquil
digamos que fue allí donde se
familiarizó con la economía y
particularmente con el sector bancario
fue el primer paso de una carrera propia
de las películas de Hollywood todo un
ejemplo de ascensor social
[Música]
de esta forma en 1993 completó un mba y
ya para finales de esa misma década
llegó a liderar la asociación de bancos
privados del Ecuador entre los años 1994
y 2012 salvo por algún pequeño intervalo
de tiempo fue el presidente del banco
Guayaquil Gracias quizás esa experiencia
en agosto de 1999 lasso fue nombrado
ministro de economía pero su poco
feeling con el presidente jamil mauath
forzó su renuncia tan solo un mes
después el Ecuador en aquella época era
un absoluto desastre el país se
enfrentaba a una debacle económica
marcada por un déficit fiscal del 12%,
una moratoria sobre la deuda externa y
una inflación descontrolada fue el
contexto explosivo que terminó con la
dolarización de la economía
por fortuna para él la renuncia de lasso
de alguna forma lo mantuvo al margen de
todo este cataclismo lo que permitió que
en 2012 se lanzara el terreno político
optando a la mismísima presidencia Claro
que este proceso llevaría tiempo
concretamente tuvo que hacer tres
intentos hasta dar por fin en la Diana
en 2021 Ecuador le daba Guillermo la
sola dirección del país
la idea En aquel momento parecía muy
clara sepultar de una vez por todas al
correísmo que ya había sido herido por
Moreno bueno eso y Buscar también la
reactivación económica mediante dos vías
una reforma fiscal y una reforma laboral
también prometió una política de
vacunación rápida contra la pandemia del
coronavirus En este gobierno que hoy
nace en este nuevo siglo del
republicanismo que estamos a punto de
arrancar
termina la era de los caudillos
termina la era de los caudillos sin
embargo queridos amigos amigas hay cosas
que son más fáciles de prometer que de
hacer y sabéis que este es un buen
ejemplo atentos
[Música]
una legitimidad hipotecada con parálisis
parlamentaria
[Música]
el 24 de mayo del 2021 en medio de una
economía diezmada por la pandemia el
nuevo gobierno tomó las riendas sin
embargo la principal preocupación no era
ese sino los problemas de gobernabilidad
con los que se estrenaba la presidencia
y es que en Ecuador las elecciones
legislativas las elecciones al
parlamento coinciden con la primera
vuelta de las presidenciales donde las
apenas obtuvo en torno al 20% de los
votos esto hizo que pese a su Victoria
la asamblea nacional se quedara al borde
de ser controlada por la oposición algo
que terminó ocurriendo precisamente por
una jugada fallida del propio partido de
gobierno Y es que veréis para sumar
votos en la segunda vuelta Guillermo
lassos apoyó en el partido social
cristiano alcanzó un acuerdo legislativo
que le otorgaba este último partido la
presidencia del futuro parlamento
sin embargo el 14 de mayo de 2021 tan
solo 10 días antes de la toma de
Posesión los social cristiano rompieron
su Alianza con lasso después de que el
partido del presidente el movimiento
creó no apoyará la lección del candidato
que habían presentado para presidir la
legislatura ecuatoriana los diputados
del gobierno entrante prefirieron
respaldar la candidatura de pachakutic
de tendencia indigenista con la idea de
tender puentes con un sector que podría
resultar clave Para futuras reformas El
problema es que con ello perdieron la
posibilidad de manejar cómodamente la
asamblea nacional el partido del
presidente apenas cuenta con 28 de los
137 diputados que integran este
parlamento
y eso no es todo con el paso del tiempo
cada vez más legisladores han declarado
independientes el resultado una
incapacidad absoluta para hacer ningún
cambio relevante la asamblea no está con
lazo
digamos que el gobierno de hecho ha dado
por perdida cualquier posibilidad de
poder hacer absolutamente nada con esta
asamblea por ejemplo según el
observatorio legislativo de la fundación
ciudadanía y desarrollo de Ecuador
durante el primer año de la legislatura
esto es entre mayo del 2021 y mayo del
2022 la asamblea nacional aprobó 14
leyes de esas 14 leyes 13 fueron
proyectos presentados en la anterior
legislatura al final solo tres leyes
salieron adelante y no penséis que a
partir de ese momento las cosas forman
mejor para nada la desvinculación entre
los legisladores y El Ejecutivo es total
y sabéis que el propio presidente no lo
ha podido dejar más claro fijaos que a
la asamblea nacional salvo rosas
excepciones que sí las hay de algunas
asambleístas serios patrióticos en la
mayoría no les importa el Ecuador le dan
la espalda al Ecuador lo único que le
interesa a ellos es negocios personales
intereses partidistas egoísmos vanidades
o celos y lo que me demuestra a mí es
que debo de gobernar de aquí en adelante
sin considerar que existe la asamblea
nacional mucha atención gobernar sin
considerar que existe la asamblea
nacional estas amigos la clave de todo
lo que viene a continuación
[Música]
gobernando a lo judini
si tenemos en cuenta la ausencia de
apoyo legislativo y una victoria
electoral que en gran medida se produjo
gracias a un pacto con un partido con el
que ha roto por completo resulta
evidente que las está encadenado de pies
y manos a la hora de impulsar reformas
de calado en 2021 por ejemplo nada más
comenzar su mandato el nuevo gobierno
presentó una ley de creación de
oportunidades una especie de megaley que
aspiraba a sacar adelante un gran
paquete de cambios lo que nos sentó nada
bien en la asamblea una asamblea que
forzó al gobierno a partir esta especie
de megaley en dos proyectos diferentes
por un lado una reforma fiscal y por
otro una laboral la primera que había
sido consensuada con el fmi salía
adelante y entra en vigor en noviembre
de 2021 en términos generales supuso un
considerable incremento de impuestos con
el objetivo de incrementar la
recaudación en casi 2.000 millones de
dólares Es decir para recaudar casi un
20% más un objetivo que tal y como
podéis ver en pantalla se está
cumpliendo a la perfección Mientras
tanto sobre la reforma laboral no se han
producido más que rumores de hecho
realmente la reforma fiscal pues salió
adelante básicamente porque los
legisladores no se pusieron de acuerdo
para presentar un frente común contra el
elegido gobierno eso y porque subir
impuestos tampoco es popular pero con la
cuestión laboral la reacción ha sido
mucho más contundente y ojo que hablamos
de un país donde la informalidad en el
mercado de trabajo afecta casi tres
cuartas partes de todos los empleos del
país por supuesto ya os podéis hacer una
idea de cómo son los salarios
[Música]
incluso la reticencias de la asamblea
hacia este gobierno hizo que a duras
penas y prácticamente por los pelos se
aprobara la ley de seguridad integral y
es que para que os hagáis una idea de lo
que estamos hablando entre febrero de
2021 y noviembre de 2022 vio como 416
reclusos perdieron la vida en 11
masacres carcelarias entre bandas
dedicadas al narcotráfico es decir que
lidiar con el poder legislativo se ha
convertido en una auténtica pesadilla
Claro que ese no ha sido el único
problema con el que ha tenido que lidiar
lasso Ecuador se está convirtiendo en un
importante centro para la distribución
internacional de narcóticos
y ojo porque según la misma ONU Ecuador
es ya el tercer país del mundo con más
incautaciones de coca y de hecho en
abril del 2022 lasso tuvo que decretar
el estado de excepción Y desplegar
10.000 efectivos policiales en las
provincias de guayas manabí esmeraldas
para contrarrestar la violencia generada
por el narcotráfico en dichas regiones
Claro que apenas dos meses más tarde el
presidente tuvo que volver a hacer lo
mismo en varias provincias para frenar
un nuevo levantamiento indígena contra
las políticas del gobierno
es decir que entre unas cosas y otras la
presidencia de lasso prácticamente se ha
convertido en una interminable pesadilla
de hecho las buenas noticias para el
presidente parecen ser únicamente las
que tienen que ver con la política
exterior eso ha sido elogiado por Joe
biden al mismo tiempo que ha firmado un
acuerdo de libre comercio con China y
todo apunta que Próximamente puede
llegar también el acuerdo de libre
comercio con los propios Estados Unidos
felicito al presidente por dar un
ejemplo regional en materia de seguridad
migración y progreso económico Estados
Unidos seguirá siendo un socio
estratégico de Ecuador para generar
desarrollo y oportunidades en nuestra
nación Joe biden 20 de diciembre de 2022
pero más allá de eso entre la violencia
las sublevaciones indígenas y el choque
total con la asamblea el mandato del
presidente parece totalmente agotado
cuanto menos sin margen de maniobra y
sabéis que es justo aquí cuando para
intentar recuperar la iniciativa
política las decidió jugarse todo por el
todo atentos
[Música]
el naufragio final
con todo en su contra y con muchos
analistas dando por agotado su mandato y
considerando lo fallido Guillermo lasso
decidió echarse en brazo de las urnas y
lo hizo teniendo apenas entre el 20 y el
30% de la aprobación Popular sin embargo
tanto el presidente como su propio
gabinete consideraron que si las
preguntas se enfocaban correctamente el
Sí podría ganar con facilidad se tiraron
a una piscina vacía este gobierno tome
este referéndum como lo que siempre fue
la oportunidad de escucharlos de
aprender e incluso de reconectar con
ustedes la idea del oficialismo fue en
cierta forma brillante si hubiera
funcionado proponer una reforma
constitucional que tocara políticas
públicas vinculadas a las iniciativas
del propio gobierno durante el año
anterior de tal manera que la victoria
del Sí pues sirviera como una muestra de
respaldo Popular a su gestión una idea
Aparentemente Genial que sin embargo nos
obliga a ser fieles a los derechos de
autor esta misma estrategia fue la
utilizada por luz la calle Pou en
Uruguay en marzo del 2022 os hablamos de
ella aquí en visualpolitik
Eso sí En el caso de Ecuador las
reformas planteadas hacían referencia a
otras reformas más o menos importantes
en síntesis permitir las tradición de
Ecuatorianos vinculados con el crimen
organizado garantizar la autonomía de la
fiscalía general del estado reducir el
número de diputados en el parlamento
reducir el número oficial de partidos
políticos cambiar la composición y
devolver a la asamblea parte de las
competencias del Consejo de
participación ciudadana y control social
un órgano creado por Correa Y por último
algunos cambios en la política de
conservación ambiental como el
reconocimiento del pago de
compensaciones como podéis ver ningún
gran cambio Pero eso sí reformas en su
mayoría más o menos razonables capaces a
priori de lograr un amplio apoyo
político
lazo se lo jugó todo una carta aun
cuando el riesgo no era precisamente
pequeño sin apoyo legislativo con las
bandas criminales envalentonadas y una
legitimidad de origen cuestionada los
partidos correístas y los distintos
movimientos indígenas se lanzaron en
tromba contra las reformas abogando y
haciendo campaña por el no el desenlace
final no solo supuso un misil en la
línea de flotación del barco sobre el
que navega este gobierno sino que
incluso puede llegar a traducirse en el
Renacer del correísmo en el país y es
que la sono consiguió la aprobación de
ni una sola de sus medidas las ocho
consultas Fueron rechazadas por la
población con un promedio del 56% de
Voto negativo
Y no sólo eso a la par con estos pésimos
resultados los candidatos respaldados
por el mismísimo Rafael Correa
triunfaron también en los principales
distritos del país recordad que las
elecciones también contemplaban la
elección de las autoridades locales
donde Revolución ciudadana el partido
correísta obtuvo la mayoría de votos en
Quito y Guayaquil a estas alturas el
presidente lasso parece arrinconado por
todos los frentes un legislativo
absolutamente en contra una ciudadanía
descontenta con su mandato y ahora para
colmo múltiples jurisdicciones
gobernadas por sus opositores la
pregunta Entonces es que demonios
Podemos esperar para el resto de su
mandato pues visto lo visto no mucho o
más bien Nada de nada cualquier otro
desenlace sería sorprendentemente dada
la coyuntura política del país en estos
momentos el gobierno de lasso parece una
presa fácil para que los partidos
opositores las organizaciones indígenas
y todas las plataformas políticas se
tienen contra se lancen directamente
contra su cuello Así que si quiere
mantener su sillón y algo de oxígeno en
su gobierno a la zona le va a quedar
otra que negociar y sobre todo claudicar
ahora bien puede que ni siquiera con eso
sea el nombre de Rafael Correa vuelve a
estar sobre la mesa logramos lo
imposible volvimos a ser Revolución
ciudadana Rafael Correa Sí vale puede
que la derrota de lasso tenga mucho que
ver con las expectativas fallidas pero
Es evidente que Ecuador no quiere pasar
página no al menos del todo sea como sea
ahora comienza una nueva etapa y
llegados hasta aquí la pregunta es para
ti crees que volveremos a ver a Rafael
Correa al frente de Ecuador que ha
fallado con laso estamos ante el fin de
su gobierno dejamos por aquí abajo
vuestros comentarios y hablamos debate
por supuesto si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho una vez más Muchas gracias
por estar ahí un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]